hi hey nice to meet you in the flesh
alright Sierra Reynolds better who are
you I know nothing
all right all right yeah for this really
yeah I loved him but I really yeah I got
that fire festival every year started in
May 1904 then the first sea-based
invasion happened in like 1911 Wow how
do you that that's really so I don't
know a big fan what's your favorite kind
of music
indie yeah indie favorite band favorite
band are in the squib re in the squid
how do you know Ari and do we not know
Ari in the square I love re in this way
get out of here no David start on three
one two three Island romance oh my god
wait is this every picture together you
got the X I don't know I just got out of
a pretty serious relationship but what
about you I think says College actually
not even the little thing anything no
I'm like I work I have cats this is like
multi-year relationship what did they
break up
you really haven't dated anyone no I
know one you're here no right yeah being
real honest love it
states back like five years twitter
facebook Instagram
what do I do Brad it's kind of weird
yeah she spells on MySpace would you be
able to help me find someone's social
security number what okay totally random
question when I say the name Brad what
comes to mind my brother's name is Brad
what do you mean what am I really
his name is Brad what cute mean you give
me a boyfriend no no my brother's name
is Brad we're like super close like best
friends we live together I gotta go are
you okay
you need water off the hip I can't hear
you I'm so sorry about that
no it's okay never happened before so a
little bit of a confession I googled you
before the state and I thought you were
gonna be an [ __ ] and you're really a
great guy yeah me too
oh my god I'm so happy you should give
Brad a call right I'm gonna call him
after really like dinner right now right
now right now
that's crazy
I'm so into you